la commission d' enquête parlementaire
sur le coc u19 a vendu son rapport un
rapport accablant un rapport à charge
contre le gouvernement une commission
pilotée par les députés lr à l'assemblée
nationale et qui parle de
sous-estimation du risque ou encore de
pilotage défaillant de la crise alors
que de leur côté les députés et l'om ont
préféré parler d'un rapport partiel et
un rapport partial
eric ciotti le rapporteur de la
commission qui a déclaré ne pas vouloir
que la commission ne se transforme en un
tribunal a parlé d'une gestion chaotique
de la crise
un rapport donc adopté ce matin par les
députés à l'exception des députés lrm
qui ont préféré s abstenir concernant ce
vote
au total ce sont pas moins de 50
audition 130 heures d'auditions sur six
mois énormément de personnalités ont été
entendues par les députés des membres du
gouvernement des mises la santé ancien
ministre la santé des anciens membres du
gouvernement également à l'image
d'edouard philippe l'ancien premier
ministre mais également des
personnalités du monde scientifique
comme le professeur didier raoult et 96
plainte contre le gouvernement ont été
adressés à la cour de justice de la
république a déclaré le chef de file des
députés aient l'air à l'assemblée
nationale damien abad qui dénoncent un
manque d'anticipation du gouvernement
mais aussi des messages contradictoires
notamment sur la polémique autour du
masque il a également parlé des grands
oubliés de cette crise sanitaire en
faisant référence aux personnes âgées
épisode maisons de retraites alors
qu'eric ciotti
de son côté surenchérit il a déclaré que
la gestion du corps aux navires il ne
devrait pas être mise entre les mains du
ministère de la santé mais plutôt du
ministère de l'intérieur les députés
aient l'air ont déclaré qu'ils étaient
déterminés à faire la lumière et dire la
vérité aux français concernant cette
gestion de crise du coronavirus de son
côté le sénat à majorité à droite on
craint les mêmes conclusions que ceux
qui ont été déclarées ici à l'assemblée
nationale par la commission denquête le
sénat qui à elle sa propre commission
denquête et qui devra examiner son
rapport la semaine prochaine